(rock music)
- Woo!
(Jonas clapping)
- We're back with John,
Nick and Kevin Jonas.
(crowd cheering)
- Woo!
So in addition to Rob's backstage popcorn,
the brothers have been working
on another exciting venture
their upcoming residency in Las Vegas.
(audience cheers)
(audience clapping)
I am so excited to come see this.
Like I said, I loved your show so much
when I saw you at the Bowl.
So I'm so stoked about this.
What's new?
What's gonna be happening?
- Well there's a lot.
I mean, we haven't played a
show since October last year.
And so we're obviously very excited
to get back on the stage.
And, this residency was actually
supposed to happen pre-COVID
and then COVID hits.
So this is a long time overdue for us
to bring an exciting to our fans in Vegas.
And, it's a great town for live music.
And I just can't wait to
get out there and play.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh so this should
have happened a long time ago?
- Yeah.
- Oh man.
- Maybe some special guests maybe-
- That's exciting.
Don't invite me, mama will show up.
(group laughing)
- I will just show up.
I'm just gonna show up singing.
(contestants laughing)
I hear that you're back
in the studio though.
So I'm excited about
that, I love your record.
(audience cheers)
(crowd clapping)
- When we're back in studio,
we're writing, recording,
and getting that process started.
And finding inspiration everywhere.
So, we're ready to get it out there
for the world Hopefully,
by the end of this year, we'll see.
- That's so exciting.
- I love it, looking at them like right?
- October eleventh
(Nick laughing)
- Well to combine their love of popcorn
with their upcoming residency,
it is time for a clever game.
It's cleverly named called,
"What's Poppin' in Vegas".
(upbeat music)
♪ What's popping in Vegas ♪
You better sing Jesse.
We are here at our Nick
Offerman Lectern of Integrity.
He is what are you,
- The Nick Jonas Lectern of Integrity.
- I love it, I love it.
Nick, you just got one uped.
We are at the Nick Jonas
Lectern of Integrity.
I like it, I'm gonna keep it there.
Especially when Offerman comes back.
- What is this?
- Teams are,
what is this crap?
Teams are me and Joe,
versus is Nick and Kevin.
- Boo.
- So I, exactly.
I love your spirit already.
I'm used to beating Nick on the voice,
so this should be easy.
- Not true.
- Maybe once.
We need a host.
Oh Lord, are you there?
- [Lord] I am here, how
are you doing Kelly?
- I'm great, tell me
about the winning team.
- [Lord] Hey Kevin, Nick,
Joe, how you boys doing?
I'll tell you what, I don't
care what anyone says,
y'all my favorite creation.
That's what I'm talking about.
- Y'all my favorite creation.
- Thank you.
- [Lord] Now here's how this game works.
I'm gonna ask a question that
has to do with Las Vegas
in some way or another.
And if you know the answer,
you're gonna hit your
button and let me have it.
Now you can hit the button
before I'm done talking,
but why deprive yourself
of my golden voice?
Now also the commandments don't apply here
because steals are allowed.
Okay?
- Okay.
- [Lord] Now Kelly and
Joe, you are playing
for the left side of the audience.
- Woo!
(audience cheering)
- [Lord] Make some noise
y'all, make some noise.
And Kevin and Nick, you
playing for the right side
of the audience.
- We got you.
- There you go.
(audience cheers)
Now I will tell you the
prize on the line here
is of biblical proportions because
everyone on the winner's
side of the audience
will get two tickets to
see the Jonas Brothers
Live in Las Vegas.
(audience cheers)
- Don't fail.
- [Lord] All right.
- Don't fail
- [Kelly] I will replace him
- [Lord] Here's your first question.
- Oh, okay.
- [Lord] According to experts,
what game in Las Vegas
has the best odds for you winning?
- Baccarat.
- It is not Baccarat.
I'm sorry, you can steal
now Kelly, come on.
- What were you gonna say?
I was gonna, we don't have a light.
- Oh, there we go.
(Kelly mumbles)
I'm gonna go,
- I don't know, I don't know.
- I'm gonna go with Black Jack.
- Jack Black.
- It is Black Jack.
(audience cheers)
- I didn't know, I didn't know.
- [Lord] Oh that's what I'd like to hear.
Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] Now this one is for both teams.
No buzzing in on this one.
Whoever can guess closer,
without going over this number.
We'll get five points.
I'm gonna ask Nick,
I'm gonna ask Nick and
Kevin first to guess.
Here's the question?
Approximately how many weddings
a day happen in Las Vegas?
- Oh my gosh.
- 120.
- Nah, that's too high,
It's too high, sure.
- 30.
Do we answer now?
- You can answer now.
Yes you may.
- 37.
- Okay, that's your guess.
All right now Kelly and Joe approximately
how many weddings a day happen
in Las Vegas do you think?
- Go for it, go for it.
- 75.
- 75 Bob.
- 75, okay.
Well Kelly and Joe,
you win because the correct answer is 300.
It is actually 300.
- I'm just gonna say I was 120.
Nick's like, there's no way, way too high.
The next one's worth 20 so,
- [Lord] Okay fine, the
next one is worth 20.
You said it and I'll make it so.
Here is the question worth 20 points.
Where in Las Vegas are the Jonas Brothers
playing from June 3rd, till the 11th.
- Don't mess this up Kev.
You can do it, take it away.
Park MGM Theater.
- It is The Park MGM Theater.
(audience cheers)
And you have won, Nick
and Kevin you have won.
It's a miracle.
- It's not about how you start,
it's how you finish.
- Oh my God.
- That's how it goes.
- Congrats or whatever.
- Thank you.
Of course the real winner
is today's entire audience
because you're all getting two tickets to-
(audience cheers)
Live In Vegas exclusive
in Dolby Live at Park MGM.
So everyone at home, tickets
are on sale right now.
Great game, we are great partners.
Great game, great game.